if you were to study your own brain
introspect how do you think what's your
thinking process like we'll talk about
the writing process of putting it down
on paper uh which is quite rigorous and
famous at uh Amazon but how do you when
you sit down maybe alone maybe with
others and thinking through this High
dimensional space and looking for
Creative
Solutions creative paths forward is
there something you can
about that process it's such a good
question and I honestly don't know how
it works if I did I would try to explain
it I know it involves lots of wandering
yeah so I you know when I sit down to
work on a problem I know I don't know
where I'm going so to to go in a
straight line to be efficient efficiency
and invention are sort of at odds
because invention real invention not
incremental Improvement incremental
Improvement is so important in in every
Endeavor in everything you do you have
to work hard on also just making things
a little bit better but I'm talking
about real invention real lateral
thinking that requires wandering and you
have to give yourself permission to
wander I think a lot of
people
um they feel like wandering is
inefficient and should you know like
when when I sit down at a meeting I
don't know how long the meeting is going
to take if we're trying to solve a
problem because if I did then I'd
already I I know there's some kind of
straight line that we're drawing to the
solution the reality is we may have to
wander for a long time and I do like
group invention I think there's really
nothing more fun than sitting at a
whiteboard with a a n you know a group
of smart people and spitballing and
coming up with new ideas
and objections to those ideas and then
solutions to the objections and going
back and forth so like um you know
sometimes you wake up with an idea in
the middle of the night and sometimes
you sit down with a group of people and
go back and forth and both things are
really pleasurable and when you wander I
think one key thing is to
notice a good idea and to to to maybe to
notice the kernel of a good idea maybe
pull it that string cuz I I don't think
uh good ideas come fully
formed 100% right in fact when I come up
with what I think is a good idea and it
survives kind of the first level of
scrutiny you know that I do in my own
head and I'm ready to tell somebody else
about the idea I will often say look it
is going to be really easy for you to
find objections to this idea but work
with me there's something there there's
something there and that is intuition
yeah you because it's really easy to
kill new
ideas in the beginning because they do
have so many so many easy objections to
them so you need to uh you need to kind
of forewarn people and say look I know
it's going to take a lot of work to get
this to a fully formed idea let's get
started on that it'll be fun so you got
that ability to say cosign in you
somewhere after
all maybe not on math in a different
domain yeah there are a thousand ways to
be smart by the way and that is a really
like when I go around you know and I
meet people I'm always looking for the
way that they're smart and you find it
is that's one of the things that makes
the world so interesting and fun is that
it is not it's not like IQ is a single y
Dimension there are people who are smart
in so such unique ways yeah you just
gave me a good response to when somebody
calls me an idiot on the internet you
know that's a thousand ways to be smart
sir well but they might tell you yeah
but there are a million to be ways to be
done yeah right I feel like that's a
Mark Twain
quote